bien sûr c'est demain qu'une française
pourrait devenir présidente du Parlement
européen à la veille de l'élection l'UDF
Nicole Fontaine apparaît en effet comme
favorite face aux socialiste portugais
Mario Suarez elle était jusqu'alors
vice-présidente du Parlement portrait
signé Pascal verdotarnasri
elle arrive souvent sur la pointe des
pieds Nicole Fontaine y compris pour les
réunions de son groupe
efficace et assidu parfois discrète ce
jour-là il avait oublié où se trouvait
son siège mais toujours déterminé
depuis les élections européennes le PPE
le Parti populaire européen le vent en
poupe et Nicole Fontaine revendique le
poste de président du Parlement
principal atout de cette avocate
spécialiste des relations entre l'État
et l'enseignement privé son expérience
élue en 84 Nicole Fontaine connaît
toutes les arcanes de la politique
communautaire dans les rapports toujours
conflictuels avec les ministres
européens elle est chargée de mettre un
peu d'huile dans les rouages sens du
compromis mais fermeté nous sommes
parvenus
arracher au Conseil
47,5 millions d'écus pour les années 98
cette enveloppe financière est tout à
fait insuffisant
une conviction c'est une conviction
européenne servie par un très grand
professionnalisme et une féminité qui ne
s'en laisse pas compter
nouvelle coqueluche des médias français
qui ont longtemps boudé les jeux du
Parlement Nicole Fontaine n'est pas dupe
elle sait qu'il lui faudra redonner un
peu de chair un peu de vie à une
institution dont l'image est brouillée
elle s'est aussi face à son concurrent
Mario Soares le poids lourd des
socialistes européens que rien n'est
joué les femmes n'en effet n'ont pas le
droit à l'erreur
je crois que nous sommes condamnés à la
qualité
parce que si nous devenions tout d'un
coup médiocre ou
ne faisons pas bien notre travail et
bien nous serions beaucoup plus vite
chez que les hommes une profession de
foi qui en vaut bien d'autres c'est
pourquoi Nicole Fontaine poursuit sa
dernière campagne entre Bruxelles Paris
et Strasbourg avec opiniâtreté